today hey I'm Derek Bradley Derek
Bradley
drinks are on action
let me tell you right now there this
I requested games in the moment in the
room this is the one they've been
waiting for
Ashton found in the realm of the Dark
Souls right
but it's more about the game
yes so like we know that the main things
gameplay-wise that people are
interacting with when they play a [ __ ]
is of course here the stamina based
combat sled like high risk but high
reward combat like really adrenaline
fuelled stuff but at the same time we've
got escamoles flair and in play there so
when people do get into those planets
tough situations there's a really easy
flow from like being Alliance having
someone else just hop in and kind of
help you out exactly yeah I love that
Africa exactly so the whole game has
been built from the ground up to be a
co-op game there's no real PvP which is
you know I love games they have it but
we just decided we wanted to do co-op
really really well so
there's those two things the third thing
is that it's a big open world game so in
our demo today what we have on the floor
here and it's a little bit of a little
bit of open world and we send people
right into a dungeon so there's like
this really was still kind of feel of
what you're doing and we get to show
people a whole cross-section but at the
same time when you play the full game is
a really big overworld that you get to
explore and the interesting thing I find
there is that when you're in the open
world
you get to tackle these these sort of
situations and stamina based combat from
a full 360 like you can come at it from
different angles where the stuff we have
in dungeons you get kind of funneled in
again yeah
[Applause]
that guy
tell us about that
yes actually
you see this
so home
I was
nice
now
while they're like
all right so this one
yes I don't get with you let's see it
there's like 18 points
whatever reasons like here in today's
work
my eyes
like
the plastic bills what
[Music]
and PC
today
teller someone
here
yes absolutely there are boss fights all
through ashen and they sort of vary you
know we've we've got boss fights we've
got stuff like giants and you can't
actually kill cuz their lease is way too
huge for a player to do it but you can
interact interact with them and like
sometimes they're really dangerous and I
just stomp on you you know so like
school you gotta watch out for them but
definitely like serious boss spice
things that like players will have to
figure out the mechanics and figure out
exactly what happened for their bosses
pretty awesome
it's always home narrative
we are those things
we use so many ways to do that I mean
even kind of like you know we've
obviously got cinematics all over the
place that help young and they kind of
lead you through the story this quest
givers there are our items kind of what
we were talking about before it's like
part of the cool thing that is
interesting about finding items as you
go even if you want to use your starting
Club you want to invest in that Club and
make it stronger as you move through the
world you'll find weapons and their
descriptions give you a little hints as
to what the story is to things sometimes
you might like more you can lore on the
weapon seat so you might not want to
equip the weapon but you want to read
about it which is kind of nice because
they really synergize with the areas
that they're placed in the story of the
of the the position that you pick them
up from you know it might be something
to do with the skeleton that you find
them on or the environment that you find
them in yeah then we can have way
one of the highlights is graded titles
Ashton
so we'll be ready to fall this year
these are quite close
it'll be on xbox it's absolutely nice ok
TV I needed to show you me yeah
absolutely absolute pleasure passion or
the game looks fantastic tell you guys
right now this might be a sleeper
you